there's my eyes okay so I am curious as
to how fast my eyes move when I'm
playing a game that requires me to look
at a lot of things at once so I thought
that the best example of that would be
ultimate custom night where there's 50
characters on the screen now I'm not
controlling the game with my eyes in any
way shape or form here but what I am
doing is in a vain way I'm trying to see
just how fast my eyes actually move you
get what I'm saying I think you get what
I'm saying so I'm gonna go into this
after I Chuck my game fuel terrible
I don't drink energy drinks I just have
that for some [ __ ] reason I'm gonna
start on 120 mode because I forget how
to play and I don't remember how this
cooks good [ __ ] Oh Rick what did I do
I've forgotten already yeah you you you
know not the heater you you you know God
I've forgotten already you know uh you
free ammo I've completely forgotten how
to play don't don't do it
I'm warning you okay so the whole point
is there's a lot to look at in this game
and so when you have a lot to look at
that means that my eyes move real fast
so my understanding is you know it's
sound logic right it's sound logic that
it be is good reflection of exactly
that's not good no thank you
[ __ ] me okay yeah you're right I did
I forgot about you because I forgot how
to play okay so I don't even know if my
eyes were moving properly there in fact
I think I closed my eyes for a second
there but you see what I'm talking about
it shows how fast my eyes move there's
nothing else to this video besides that
I'm literally just curious how fast my
eyes doth move and honestly speaking
like like I I'm not even able to
actually see what I'm doing because I
forget exactly what it is that I need to
do what if I need to do again 1 a.m. I
saw that that was what I saw no thank
you
ok I think was it 1 a.m. I think it was
1 a.m. he eyes 1 a.m. Oh God eh-eh-eh-eh
eh-eh-eh-eh I see you behind there ok
there we got 3 a.m.
oh do I have enough yes I have enough ah
I forget how to play I've completely
forgotten how to play yeah I can't
believe I'm struggling on just level no
[ __ ] no it's fine I think
ah but you see what I've been going
through this whole time see I ain't no I
ain't no dick about anything oh god I
can't even see where my eyes go
I forget what I need to do for that I
need to find a guru uh oh they're just
nevermind all good here how we doing
here and there okay good
[Music]
every hour on the hour every hour on the
hour I forgot about every hour on the
hour every hour on the hour I forgot
okay I can't even [ __ ] be 150 mode
I'm so goddamn out of it I'm so not
where I once was I can beat this I can
do this this is easy this is nothing you
move already
ah this one here [ __ ] dicks ass dicks
there you are
okay here's a common I'm boned ah piss
in my cornflakes
this is not that hard this is not that
hard just got to be careful about where
my mouse egos if I could I could control
this with my eye balls not sure if that
would be better or worse in fact I think
that would be much much infant
infinitely worse I didn't see what time
it needed to be there 3 a.m. you were
trying to ready oh I think I think I'm
fine because really I mean in all
honesty it's not that bad at level 1 you
know what I mean like it's it's just not
3 a.m. that's 2:15 that's when I need to
check it's not that bad and it's a
purist
what just I don't know what that was but
I'm trying to pay attention look at it
cool fast my eyes go god this game is so
stressful in this it's much more
stressful when there's a big pink blob
June 15 neither wit
I'm getting back into my old rhythm I'm
what does it say 4:00 a.m. okay there's
plenty of time
I got him not paying attention to Fox
ache Balloon Boy don't like that I can't
see [ __ ] now yeah oh [ __ ] I'm using a
lot too much power that's what I gotta
do I keep forgetting that every hour on
the air it's just it's just in every
hour on the hour kind of thing there's
no way no way around it unless you're
every hour on the hour
and if you're not every hour on the hour
then you're just a frickin idiot you're
an idiot a [ __ ] idiot let's try it
again why am i working so hard for this
oh [ __ ] there's still chance was it one
am easy peasy baby easy my pcs can I
please just see what's buying there you
suck okay now moving at lightning speed
it's easy it's super easy so easy cut
that so close you lady you yeah [ __ ] I
keep forgetting to reopen that as soon
as I close it my little old tactic there
oh come on
oh Jesus
sure doesn't feel like 150 mode feels
like a lot more than 150 mode but alas
here I am okay 215 is the next time that
I need to be there it's fine it's fine
just shaking the rust off that's all I'm
doing
shaking the rust off this time full
concentration mode ain't nothing gonna
get in my way one a.m. Showtime
ain't no problem okay I see everything
everything is in front of me I see it
all everything it's inescapable the
amount of information that's shooting in
my mind if 4:00 a.m. that's so much time
it's so much time so much that I don't
even know what do with all the time that
I have handled like nobody's business
ease easiest of pees iasts I forget I
forgot just how much movement there
really is in this game and how many
things you need to keep an eye on so
it's I was right in that it's very
difficult to keep track of absolutely
everything but a good reflection through
these suited to be of what I'm looking
at
[ __ ] okay almost time for the show
that's okay yeah okay boy you I bought
everything let's just go ahead and get
rid of you whoa don't like that easy
appease me if three o'clock
not a problem okay here we go it's time
for the show and OOP easy okay line this
up okay eat - easy easy so easy the
easiest thing in the world oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
what I need to look for the guitar there
it is easy breezy beautiful Nick breezy
Easons make freeze UM's okay alright so
it's not impressive I understand that
it's not impressive it's not not
impressive in the least but I just
wanted to showcase why I find this way
of playing this game I know people are
all that's this stupid exploits and
cheats and I don't like that I like the
challenge of it because it really does
push you to like a limit it pushes you a
limit of how much you can keep track of
it's a juggling game I feel like that's
what the game has always been about and
now I can actually show like just how
much you need to pay attention to to try
to keep on track and those just have one
beat 550 and I know that doesn't seem
impressive but like it's its legs I'm
not gonna be able to beat this because
it took me so long to be able to beat
this in the first place but it's it's
it's the same principle right it's the
same principle
because like it's like it's just it's
this onslaught of keeping track of
everything all at once you got to do it
over and over again you got to keep it
up you gotta like
I'm not doing the right things anyway
this is not a good example because I'm
not doing it properly but you get the
general gist of it right yeah you do see
this just it's just a ton of [ __ ] to
juggle and there's something about that
[ __ ] that I that I like oh that's
not good oh [ __ ] what oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] what [ __ ] you I touch your bird all
right right no I don't want to see but
yeah right see it's kind of cool it's
kind of cool so that's all there is to
it that's what your eyes do your eyes
look at a lot of things all at once and
I'm gonna leave that there so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
got other things that you want me to use
the eye tracker on whether to showcase
my prodigious eyeball moving skills or
my the depths of my depravity let me
know down the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]